with everyone listening to fruits and
flowers these days on Twitter SLX it was
hard to ignore the GPT 4.5 rumors
especially with those hallucinations in
the model itself which I too experienced
but now with denials from three open AI
employees I was relieved to be able to
focus instead on the real news this
video is going to cover etched in
Transformers the mix trial price spiral
mid Journey V6 and the bite dance Saga
with a guest appearance from none other
than Sebastian BBC he's one of the
authors of Sparks of AGI and the F
series of models and I interviewed him
less than 36 hours ago but first let's
get to those GPT 4.5 denials here's will
Dew a senior member of open AI he was
asked GPT 4.5 turbo discoveries legit or
no he said no it's a very weird and
oddly consistent hallucination
interestingly someone else then
speculated I wonder if putting Ur GPT
4.5 turbo in the system prompt improves
performance and he said quite possible
that would be quite funny if they've
done that even though it's not GPT 4.5
by the way I don't think they have next
we have none other than samman he was
asked strangely by the same guy GPT 4.5
leak legit or no and he does seem to
have an in with open AI because he got a
response from samman saying nah I found
that quite funny all the hype bubble
burst in a single three-letter word but
just in case there was any doubt we then
get this from ru he is an open AI
employee but somewhat undercover anyway
he said you guys need to develop more
resistance to Crazy AI hype Bros there's
no 4.5 and if there was it wouldn't be
released silently and if it was released
silently you wouldn't have the API
string self dos as 4.5 and another open
AI employee replied the saddest thing
about all of this is that people's
expectations for a GPT 4.5 are so low I
have a suite of questions that I use
myself to test every new model their
questions mainly focus on mathematics
and I tested GPT 4 during the height of
the height bubble and no nothing too
significant had changed and that's why I
agree with Adrian eett I think with
notice more of a difference with GPT 4.5
but moving on to real news what is the
ET Transformer that I mentioned well
there is very little publicly available
information on this but I've dug up what
I could find essentially this new
company h. claimed to have the world's
first Transformer supercomput one
designed from the ground up to run
Transformers the Transformer
architecture is of course used in large
language models but it's also used in
computer vision and in audio and
multimodal processing anyway this
company claims to have burned in the
Transformer architecture onto a chip as
they say its Transformers etched into
silicon their custom chip code named Soo
which I'll get to in a moment as you can
see massively outperforms apparently
nvidia's h100 on tokens per second
inference translated that would allow
realtime interaction what I'm going to
do at this point just before continuing
with the technical specs is I'm going to
give you a bit of background from an
article that I think hardly anyone else
has read the article describes a pair of
21-year-old Harvard dropouts raising
multiple Millions to design an AI
accelerator chip dedicated to large
language model acceleration basically a
company betting everything on
Transformers and large language models
this article came out in May and gets
especially interesting towards the
middle the two co-founders seen below
decided to start a chip company to
design a more efficient influence
architecture for large language models
remember in conference isn't about the
training of a large language model it's
about generating its outputs anyway
here's the key quote you can't get the
kind of improvements we're getting by
being generalized you'll see more of the
improvements in a moment but they go on
you have to bet hard on a single
architecture not just on General AI but
on something more specific we think
eventually Nvidia will do this we think
the opportunity is too big to ignore
later on we learned that they're betting
everything on a particular architecture
there are others being tested like Mamba
but they're betting everything on trans
Transformers the article goes on the
rapid evolution of workloads in the AI
space could spell disaster if etched AI
specializes too much and the co-founder
admitted as much that's a real risk and
I think it's turning off a lot of other
people from going down this route but
Transformers aren't changing he said but
if the BET pays off what does that mean
well first of all it could mean 140
times the throughput per dollar think
real time interactions with models at a
very cheap price that's as compared to
the Nvidia h100 the website gives the
example of realtime voice agents where
models built on this etched in
architecture could ingest thousands of
words in milliseconds none of those
awkward pauses between asking your model
something using voice and of course
generating many more outputs much more
quickly means that you can compare among
them and pick the best just like we do
with self-consistency and just like
Alpha code 2 did and if you don't know
about Alpha code 2 do check out my video
on Gemini just quickly though what might
it mean to burn the architecture onto a
chip well here's the somewhat simplified
version Transformers are typically run
on general purpose gpus which could be
used for other things and those gpus are
then optimized through software to run
llms the etched supercomputers in
contrast would potentially be dedicated
Hardware designed from the ground up to
run Transformers essentially by etching
the Transformer architecture directly
into the Silicon every transistor could
be optimized specifically for
Transformer computations like for
example matrix multiplication which is
the core calculation going on in large
language models so yes alas that poem on
pomegranates was the result of a ton of
multiplications and additions the plan
apparently is to fully op Source the
software stack and open sourcing the
software stack would be a strategic way
in my view to draw people in to depend
on that new hardware and specializing
Hardware like this could unlock 100x
gains if architectures don't radically
change in the next year look at the
number that they promise it's expansible
up to 100 trillion parameter models that
would be about 60 times the size of GPT
4 or to kind of summarize everything
it's designed from the ground up for GPT
5 in terms of dates it's potentially not
that long away with the chip being
slated to be available in 2024 they say
that they're doing a series a at the
beginning of next year seeking funds
they say most investors are skeptical
and rightfully so because what they see
is a pair of undergrads trying to tackle
the semiconductor industry so if all of
this is next year why am I covering it
now well firstly because if it works it
would be crazy transformative for
generative Ai and secondly let's be
honest if this is the thing that changes
the industry I want you to be able to
say that you heard it here first but
it's now time for something that's
available today that's M trial's mixture
of experts that's why it's called a mix
trial 8 * 7 billion parameter model it's
open sourced and matches or beats GPT
3.5 not only in benchmarks and not just
in leaderboards matching GPT 3.5 5 and
beating Gemini Pro but also more
significantly in price a week ago when
the Mixr model was announced it was $2
per 1 million tokens hours later
together compute dropped the pricing by
70% days later it was cut 50% further by
Abacus AI to 30 cents per 1 million
tokens then just 3 days ago deep infra
went to 27 cents per million tokens and
you can probably see where I'm going
here what happened well we learned one
provider was offering mix trial for free
for both input and output models are not
only getting more performance at a
dramatic rate they're getting cheaper at
an even more dramatic rate combine the
two and it really makes you wonder where
we be at the end of 2024 for
intelligence per dollar how about for
example gp4 level reasoning on a 13
billion parameter model here's what
Sebastian bck one of the lead authors of
Sparks of AGI and the Five series of
models told me just 36 hours ago and
it's completely an open question at the
moment what kind of capabilities we're
going to be able to achieve we don't
know but from what I'm seeing in terms
of the performance we're able to extract
at 1 billion at three billion and what I
know of the big models like gp4 I think
there is room at least for the reasoning
part to be enabled already at 13 billion
parameters he's so driven in this
mission to solve reasoning that his eyes
aren't even focused on getting llms onto
a phone that's despite recent news that
we can fit up to 10 billion parameters
on device as Qualcomm have boasted I
thought that you were deliberately
targeting around 10 billion to get it on
a phone but it seems like not no not
necessarily I mean the the the bar of
being on the phone I mean it's a bar
that I like but for me personally it's
really more about the scientific quest
of what what are the minimal ingredients
that are needed to achieve a level of
intelligence which is similar to
something like gp4 that's the real
question to me if you're interested in
learning more about the f 2 Series of
models I've done a video on it on my
channel and if you're interested in the
full juicy interview it's on AI insiders
you also get podcasts exclusive
tutorials and a personal message from me
of course I appreciate that not everyone
can afford the $24 something I think it
works out at for the annual sub so I
deeply appreciate you just watching
these videos and leaving comments and
likes and of course all the research I
do for AI insiders massively benefits my
analysis for the main AI explain channel
two more fun bits though before I go
first bite dance a multi hundred billion
dollar company is apparently secretly
using open AI Tech to build a competitor
they really just don't want to get
caught of course using the outputs of
models like gp4 to improve other models
has long been known about it's a key
technique behind the Orca series of
models and indeed the F series of models
both of those were of course in
partnership with Microsoft but it's
actually against the terms of conditions
for other companies to do that but as
the headline says the frenzied race to
win in generative AI means that even the
biggest player ERS are cutting Corners
by Dance by the way are behind Tik Tok
and as the article restates it's in
direct violation of open ai's terms of
service which state that model output
can't be used to quote develop any AI
models that compete with our products
and services nevertheless internal bite
dance documents confirm that the open AI
API has been relied on to develop its
foundational llm code named project seed
apparently during nearly every phase of
development including for training and
evaluating the model employees
apparently are well aware of the
implications and they had plans to
whitewash the evidence in response about
36 hours ago open AI banned bite dance
from chat PT due to and here's some
irony possible Data Theft I invite you
to let me know in the comments what you
think of all of that now I did warn you
at the start about Twitter rumors but
I'm going to make one slight exception
for two reasons first because it was
more of a statement and second because
it comes from the head of research at by
Dan his name is quangang and he said
this recently he's uncertain about GPT 5
but a super strong model more powerful
than Gemini is expected to arrive
anytime now you might have thought he
meant GPT 4.5 but no he was asked open
source and he said open model weights is
he referring to project seed here well
time will tell and when asked when open
source catches gpc4 do you think open AI
will just wait for that to happen he
said we don't settle for catching up
with gp4 we outpace GPT 5 I'm not
holding my breath on Project succeed but
let me know what you think let me end
with this preview images for Mid Journey
V6 just as I observed with image in 2
the real breakthrough for me seems to be
the added level of photo realism of
course I'd love to hear what you think
there is still a slight smoothness to
them but when you upscale them using
magnific then the woman if not the text
in the background looks exceptionally
realistic as always let me know what you
think thank you so much for watching to
the end and have a wonderful
day